be casting yet we're not finished
lakers season comes to an end after
having to uh go through the tournament
to get there and they are knocked out
in six games by the phoenix suns and uh
anthony davis post game
hey anthony it was pretty obvious how
much the groin was hampering you early
could you just take us through what it
felt like and what was your
mindset and how you were trying to
figure out if you were going to be able
to stay and
do anything on either end um
just wanted to be out there for the team
you know in a situation
when to go home i obviously didn't want
to just lay down and
not be able to do what i can um
it never really felt good but
like i said you know i you know once
again just a competitive nature and me
to go out and help the team
as best as i could um my body didn't
agree
so uh team fall
i mean we fought you know um
may runs you know guys left all i
left it all out on the floor uh tonight
and uh
you know get ready for next year you
know get ready to have a full off season
um everyone hell up you know especially
you know the guys that
you know um so you heard a lot this year
um feel your body just rush your bodies
and
get ready um for next season that's all
we can do that's what i'm gonna do
let the body heal and get right back to
it